- [David] Hello Kim.
- [Kim] Hey David.
- [David] So let's talk about
the Lost Colony at Roanoke.
- [Kim] So this is something
I've been learning a lot about lately,
and I think is really interesting.
You know, we often think about this
just in terms of the spookiness of,
there's this colony and it disappeared,
and we still don't know
what happened to it.
But actually, I think it has a lot to say
about the process of
colonization in the New World,
and the many political, and weather,
and economic factors that
went into making a colony
successful or not successful.
- [David] So set this up for me.
What is going on during the
period of this early settlement
of what they called Virginia,
but actually turned out to be, where Kim?
- [Kim] North Carolina.
So this on the outer
banks, and it's today,
it's still Roanoke Island,
but one of these sort of barrier islands
off the coast of North Carolina.
- [David] So, a great place to put a ship?
- [Kim] Actually, what they call this area
is the Graveyard of the Atlantic.
- [David] So I'm hearing not so much.
- [Kim] Right, so this is an area
where there are a lot of shoals,
lots of ships run aground there.
If you ever go to one of the
museums on the outer banks,
you can see this incredibly
long listing of all of the ships
that sank off the coast of North Carolina.
It is a very difficult place to sail.
- [David] What year is
it when we first see,
when we see the first
colonization attempt at Roanoke?
The first expedition.
- [Kim] Right, this all
starts in the late 1570s
with a man named Humphrey Gilbert,
and Gilbert is convinced--
- [David] Is this him?
- [Kim] This is actually
Sir Walter Raleigh.
- [David] Oh, he is cute.
- [Kim] Yes, Gilbert's
half-brother as it turns out.
So Sir Walter Raleigh's half-brother,
Humphrey Gilbert, thinks
that it might be possible
to make your way to
the Indies and fabulous riches.
Make that line a little bit bigger.
By going on top of North America.
So he thinks there's a waterway here.
So he convinces Queen Elizabeth,
then on the throne of England,
to give him a charter to
try to plant a colony somewhere
on this side of North America.
- [David] So they're looking
for the Northwest Passage,
is what they're looking for.
- [Kim] They're looking
for the Northwest Passage.
They're hoping that they can find gold,
and what they want to do
more than anything else
is just mess up Spain's
chances in the New World.
Because Spain, starting
with Christopher Columbus,
has been the leading old
world power in the New World.
They are just like, trucking
back the gold and silver,
and most of what England has
done up until this point,
is find Spanish ships that are coming back
from Mexico, from the West Indies,
and put what are called
privateers, which is a nice word
that the English used to
mean pirate, to steal things.
- [David] State-sanctioned piracy.
- [Kim] State-sanctioned piracy.
- [David] So like, Shakespeare is like
a young man at this time, right?
- [Kim] Yes.
- [David] Like that is the
period of Elizabethan England
that we're looking at right now.
- [Kim] Yeah, it's kind of, in some ways,
a golden age, but when you think about
how well the English are doing
when it comes to colonization,
it is not a golden age,
they are way behind.
So they're hoping maybe they
can find a northwest passage
to get all of the goodies
over here in India,
and the spice islands.
They're hoping that maybe they could
find some good minerals in this area,
get some gold of their own.
But at the very least,
they'd like a nice port
from which their ships could go out
and steal more stuff from Spanish ships.
- [David] (laughs) Sure.
- [Kim] Yeah, this is a
good, this is their plan.
- [David] So this is kind
of, if you'll permit me,
this feel analogous to the
space race during the Cold War.
- [Kim] Yeah, absolutely.
- [David] So Spain is
this economic superpower
that seems to have a one, you know,
have a leg up on England.
Just like how the Soviet
Union launched Sputnik first.
Got a satellite into orbit above Earth,
and that spurred the
United States to be like,
"No, we're gonna have a moon shot!"
- [Kim] Yeah, and it kinda turns out
the same way in some aspects,
because as we know, we're
sitting here in California,
we're speaking English,
because eventually England is going to win
its way to dominance
in this entire region.
But originally, Spain gets
off to the fastest start,
and England is just desperate to catch up.
So unfortunately, Sir
Humphrey Gilbert dies.
He is lost at sea.
- [David] So not this guy
here with Queen Elizabeth.
- [Kim] Right, then his
half-brother, Sir Walter Raleigh,
which he spelled with
no I, so we'll do that,
but today the city that's named after him,
we still spell with an I.
He picked up his half-brother's contract,
which said he had to get
a colony in the New World
within six years of 1578.
So he is under the gun to try
to get something happening
on the coast of North America
by 1584 at the latest.
So he picks up his friends,
and decides to put together,
what I kind of term
as like the Ocean's Eleven
of the actual ocean.
- [David] (laughs) Okay.
- [Kim] He finds some ship
captains, and soldiers.
- [David] A demolition's
expert, a contortionist.
(Kim laughs)
A con man.
- [Kim] Similar, this is like the,
the 1500s version of this.
He gets an artist, who
we'll talk a lot more about.
- [David] That's John White?
- [Kim] That's John White.
He gets cartographers, he gets
what he considers his A-team,
to go out and explore this coast.
Pick up where his half-brother left off.
The only problem was that
Sir Walter Ralegh and Queen
Elizabeth were sweethearts.
And she forbid him from going
on this dangerous journey.
After all, his brother had
also died on this journey.
So she loved him too
much, said "You can't go."
But his friends went.
So this is their first journey,
and they go to North Carolina.
They called it Virginia,
because this whole area they
named after Queen Elizabeth.
- [David] The Virgin Queen.
- [Kim] The Virgin Queen,
and a lot of the things
in this time period are
kinda named after her,
because all of these fellows
were trying to capture her heart.
So they go, and what's
really interesting about this
is that John White, this artist,
shows us so much about
what this area was like.
And I want to show you
some of the paintings that
he made in this time period.
- [David] So who were the native people
that this expedition encountered?
- [Kim] So they end up
on the barrier islands of North Carolina,
and this is where the colonists
will eventually settle
here, Roanoke Island.
The major Native American
groups in this area
were Algonquian-speaking.
So they are
kinda in the middle of what
we call the east coast today.
- [David] So this is a tidewater people.
- [Kim] They're a tidewater people.
You can see that they live in long houses,
like other Algonquian peoples,
and these are primarily the Secotan people
and the Croatoan people.
Initially the English people
get along with them pretty well.
They exchange skins, and
food, lots of things.
The English come back, thinking
this is a pretty good deal.
- [David] So John White and company,
John White and Sir Walter Ralegh's Eleven,
or however many, right, return to England.
- [Kim] Right, and they say,
"This is a great place for us to settle."
So then they send a second
expedition from England.
This time with just soldiers.
It's very similar to how Jamestown
is going to work out a little bit later,
which is to say they send
sailors, they send soldiers,
and they send people
who might, for example,
be good at finding gold, so artisans.
And they're hoping to
kinda get rich quick.
They think maybe there
are mountains nearby
that might have gold or gems in them,
or perhaps, they're always
asking that native people,
"Do you have anything shiny?
"Have you heard of anything
that's shiny nearby?"
Because they want to make their investors
back in England happy
by making a big profit.
- [David] So this is like halfway between
a forward operating
base and a trading post.
- [Kim] Exactly.
- [David] Okay.
- [Kim] So they're not thinking
about long-term settlement,
but they're left there over the winter
with the Secotan people,
and this is just a bunch of rowdy soldiers
who thought they were gonna
get rich quick, and they don't,
because there is no
gold in North Carolina,
not like there is in the south,
that the Spanish do so well with.
And they quickly come to grief
with the Native Americans.
They steal a lot of their food.
- [David] Who steals whose food?
- [Kim] The English steal
the food of the Secotans,
and they end up getting into a brawl
over the possible theft of a silver cup.
- [David] (laughs) Really?
- [Kim] Yeah, they think
the Native Americans
have stolen a silver cup from them.
They demand it back, the
Native Americans say,
"We don't know what you're talking about."
And then the English
kill a bunch of people.
- [David] Oh my gosh.
- [Kim] So relations that
were going pretty well,
went pretty badly over, what I think,
is kind of a minor incident.
But by the time that the uh,
supplies show up,
because the English are
sending supply ships
on a regular basis,
Sir Francis Drake, of piracy fame,
shows up with supplies, and
a bunch of these 100 men
just get back on the
ship and sail to England.
- [David] So wait, before we go back
to England with these men,
what contributed to this
disproportionate response,
of like killing a bunch of
people over a single silver cup?
- [Kim] I think a lot of it
was that many of these men,
now and on later expeditions,
are English veterans
of the war in Ireland.
So there is an Irish rebellion
against English rule there,
and the English take a very
brutal stance toward the Irish.
They just burned their villages,
they decapitate Irish people
and line their heads along sidewalks,
I'm not making this up.
- [David] Good lord.
- [Kim] So, they're veterans
of this really brutal Irish repression.
And this is something
that I think you see a lot
with English people when they first
are meeting Native Americans,
they treat them like
they treated the Irish,
which is to say, very badly.
They treat them as savages
who are different religion,
who need to be subject to the English,
and need to be taught early on
that they need to obey the English.
- [David] So what
happened after that, Kim?
- [Kim] We'll get to
that in the next video.